[Music]
now it's time for final exam when the
yapping stops and the testing begins
where the wheat is winnowed from the
chaff with the help of data our two
contestants we find out who has been
paying closer attention to the news this
week defending champion daily
walkthrough editor-in-chief Katy
freights
/ challenger townhall.com political
editor guy Benson we'll be teaming up
with Marie harf to launch Benson and
harf on Fox News Radio that debuts
Monday May 7th fairly soon okay Katy is
as we said the returning champion and a
nervous yeah guy you've been through
this before
you've got nerves of steel you know the
rules but for our viewers who may not
remember hands on buzzers I ask the
questions first one to buzz didn't gets
to answer the question you wait until I
finish asking in order to answer you
were penalized if you don't each correct
answer is worth 1 point each incorrect
detracts a point from your total best of
5 wins are you ready yes okay question
what Kanye West was not the only
celebrity criticized this week for
supporting the president in itíd states
which country music store had the
temerity to say she would have voted for
Donald Trump that Benson Shania Twain
Shania Twain from Canada we will see
rotate please don't
Shania Twain getting slammed by her fans
for saying she would have voted for
President Trump the singer who's from
Canada telling the Guardian he seemed
honest she's now apologizing on Twitter
saying she regrets answering the
question that stupid 920 fam I like some
of her music yeah and she was honest and
then was pilloried for being honest
which is sort of what happens these days
as an 18 in a single sentence that's
exactly right
question 2 there was a state visit this
week by the President of France but it
was a piece of the first lady's wardrobe
that created a huge distraction in the
media and online which item of clothing
were people talking about Haiti her hat
people don't wear hats or a big white
hat or a big white hat okay let's see if
the tape verifies your claim obviously
lots of people talking about a Melania
Trump hat that's the buzz of the picture
I must ask you according to Eric I'm
outing him the Hat he wants more on the
Hat the Hat did you like the Hat what
Katy Thurston Brauer I okay Henderson
Brauer we want to know more about the
Hat when you commit to a hat like that
you got to wear for the rest of the day
she caught it okay so our objectives are
pointing out there within this context
the correct answer is chapeau but we
will go with hat now hundred these
circumstances sorry that I make nice you
never apologize for being American
question three which lawmaker just
proudly presented a new jobs plan that
would give a guaranteed $15 an hour
government job to every single American
who wants one Benson Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders independent socialist of
Vermont
he's Bernie Sanders the correct answer
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders
reportedly ready to roll out a new
guarantee for every American you get a
government job $15 an hour with benefits
not only is this economic nonsense
it's also in my opinion grossly immoral
so here's a quick bonus follow-up if all
320 million Americans worked at the DMV
would that would be a better agency no
no okay good you and I can't give you a
point but your right question for this
is multiple choice
a woman was just fine five hundred
dollars by bureaucratic customs
officials for bringing what off an
airplane was it a filthy airplane
blanket was it an apple or was it a
Cuban cigar really okay to the tape
US Customs and Border Patrol takes a
bite out of one travelers wallet finding
her five hundred dollars for bringing an
Apple through customs the violation is
four for one Apple once again the Apple
is from Delta and I think that's the
most important part to take away from
the story yeah that's the most important
part okay so now we find her this is
where we find ourselves we have
high-level players when it's really a
varsity match what's in ali/frazier
lineup it's two to two sudden-death
question five will determine the winner
how do you both ready oh yeah okay do
you seem very calm I just really like
this so I don't when I know I know you
do so Godspeed and we like you to guy
president Trump says he is celebrating
his wife's birthday today he got her
something to mark the occasion was it a
a beautiful card be a tremendous
wristwatch or see some killer heels guy
Benson the greatest card it seems paltry
it does but that's what you're sticking
with I am greatest card roll tape please
very very special day because it's
milania's birthday do you want to tell
us would you got her maybe I didn't get
her so much I say what she has done
I got a beautiful card you know I got a
beautiful card
our judges are saying no he said
absolutely beautiful and you said the
greatest that's okay they're synonyms
effectively Thank You guy Benson Katie
I'm not saying I was secretly rooting
for you though I was
did such a great job and in fact and we
didn't even realize that you might not
went I'm going to take my pens out of
this mug and give it to guy Benson here
is your victory mug no were you with the
confused look yes which reflects reality
trust me thank you both kitty was great
to see I hope you'll talk about
congratulations for your fitness tracker